trop l'état monsieur marc le fur merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à vous monsieur le premier
ministre il porte sur la nomination très
surprenante de monsieur philippe mauguin
la tête de l'institut national de
recherche agronomique
vous persistez en effet à vouloir
imposer le directeur de cabinet de votre
ministre de l'agriculture à la
présidence de l'île rats contre l'avis
des chercheurs qu'est-ce que l'inra
c'est le premier centre européen de
recherche agronomique
c'est un fleuron français il faut à la
tête de cet organisme quelqu'un de
légitimes quelqu'un de crédible en
interne à l'égard des chercheurs mais
aussi à l'international à l'égard de la
communauté scientifique mondiale car
nous sommes observés vouloir imposer une
nomination politique à un poste jusqu'à
présent toujours d'évoluer un chercheur
est une faute morale
la communauté scientifique se sent
méprisée vouloir imposer un directeur de
cabinet en exercice à la tête d'un
établissement public dont ils assurent
jusqu'à présent la tutelle créer une
situation de conflit d'intérêts c'est
donc aussi une faute juridique
on est loin on est même très loin de la
république irréprochable prônée par
candidat hollande en 2012
présider la république s'est refusé que
tout procède d'un seul homme d'un seul
parti qui risque d'ailleurs de devenir
un clan à lors de l'examen de la loi
sympa 2 monsieur le ministre qui se veut
normalement là pour renforcer la
transparence et la démagogie et la
déontologie
quel message envoyé vous à cette
nomination militante mais il est encore
temps de revenir à cette nomination sur
cette nomination
c'est à vous monsieur le premier
ministre que la question est posée
monsieur lors c'est à vous d'y répondre
personne ne comprendrait que monsieur le
foll le futur ex employeur de monsieur
maingain répondent à votre place
c'est à vous monsieur le premier
ministre de prendre vos responsabilités
vous savez le faire je vous donne je
vous fais confiance pour que vous ne
répondiez correctement
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt furent
je vais vous répondre correctement
d'abord pour vous dire que cette
nomination effectivement et regarder et
qu'on a scrupuleusement respecté ce qui
a été la loi de geneviève fioraso sur la
transparence des nominations ce n'était
pas le cas avant je vais revenir
un comité d'experts a été donné et j'ai
simplement les noms pour que les choses
soient bien claires
madame fesco cayla présidente de
l'université de wageningen sommités
mondialement reconnu madame briand
directrice de l'agencé nationale de
recherche qui avait été d'ailleurs
chargé du plan cancer ii jean pierre
raffarin paul vialle ex-directeur
général de l'inra qui avait été membre
du cabinet de françois guillaume
laurence tubiana reconnu pour la coop 21
rené tous un inspecteur général des
finances et monsieur site herman chef de
l'inspection générale de la recherche
transparence et expertise ils ont rendu
un rapport qui a été transmis aux deux
commissions qui ont pu statuer et qui
ont monsieur jacob voté à une large
majorité à plus de 58% pour la
candidature de philippe mauguin pour ce
qui est de la république exemplaire
l'exemple est donné et vous devrez vous
allez devoir maintenant vous allez
devoir maintenant vous même c'est le
reggae vacances approchent je vous
rappelle à rosheim bruno le maire n'est
pas là mais que ce cabinet jean marc
bournigal excellent par ailleurs avait
été de dieu juste avant le départ de
jane eyre à lire céréales min à des
intentions ce que recherche et qu'il a
été renommée par le président de la
république françois hollande compte tenu
des qualités que nous leur connaissons
de la même manière monsieur pascal vinet
qui a été directeur général de l'oncf a
exercé son mandat en toute sérénité
et quand il a souhaité partir à coop de
france il a pu partir en toute
tranquillité monsieur le fur voilà
comment on répond concrètement et de
manière exemplaire
nice tu là